um
don't tell anybody
hold on
let me
explain
what's happening i know
what this
looks like
and it's not
what you think
i swear if you'll just let me get a
moment korean hey if you give me a
moment
this is orc massage
now before you go looking it up on steam
well maybe i actually i don't know if i
can show you
what's up okay
blur there's things to blur there's a
blur blur uh
blur blur
um
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no you're just an innocent and
celibate orc moving to the big city in
order to start a new life earn money and
increase your abilities so you can be
the best masseur around vip clients are
the worst of the bunch the stress they
face in their daily lives brings them to
you get to learn your clients wants and
needs so you can effortlessly take care
of any pains they may have
be careful though doing a good job may
lead to some consequences you wouldn't
want to destroy that nice image of
yourself right i am right so
if i'm reading this
correctly i am an honest orc trying to
run a reputable massage parlor everyone
hold on
you are judging a lot of things here
you're assuming a lot of things i
am a upstanding orc and i'm going to
give an orc massage
there's nothing further about this so
the whole objective of this is to go
through this whole game and try to do
the best i can at running a nice
family-friendly massage parlor okay
all right let's go into this and i will
lose the game should anything
untoward happen
hello
[Music]
what do you want come in
okay
oh look at me
if this is about the holy [ __ ]
you're a big guy ain't you yeah i mean
that's what some people have said
elixir and cut out everything every cut
sensor it blur all of it just blur the
whole screen never seen you before you
need something
a job well what kind of job
anything
you're not much of a talker huh yeah not
really let me think all right i got an
idea big guy
what's happening
what
i've been wanting to start something up
myself and you'd be perfect for it a
massage place
you know you rub people's bodies relax
them and stuff
the girls will love those big strong
myths and it uh it ain't rocket science
either
okay you got it employee con employment
contract sign here and there and here
don't worry about the details buddy
we'll talk over it later
yes
okay
[Music]
everything's on the up and up here
yup here's the place
pretty swank huh
[Music]
go on take a look around
i'm looking around let's talk about the
important stuff giving a massage i need
to learn
i need to learn
[Music]
jesus christ looking for you i got a
quick overview from this book here i'll
leave it on the table
get familiar with the place for now
practice if you need all that jazz uh
my god all right big guy let's go over
the basics and you see those dots
okay
these are the clients source
[Music]
think of your hand like a hammer and
carefully pound out their tension
you got it great try it what am i doing
what the [ __ ] my feet getting like that
try it out some more now get that blood
flowing watch my feet what am i doing
oh there we go okay all right okay
hey that's nice
when the color changes from red to green
that means the clients feeling good
once you see a heart it's time to move
on to another spot
okay the sore spot will change color
until it turns green once the circle
turns into a green heart it's good to go
you'd be careful those big old mitts
have a wide reach
make sure you don't accidentally overdo
it and stress out your client
when you use the hammer style connected
points on the body will be affected the
link points to your current spot will be
indicated with a circle looks like
there's only one source sauce left you
got this
okay good
ah
easy all right so remember how i said
mine to reach sometimes you can't use
that hammer-like hand technique you
gotta go more gently move your hands
like this yeah
when you move this motion you won't
affect any other areas some places call
for a gentle touch got it
great job now keep going until the
client looks nice and relaxed
all right
you got it
wow
i'm good at this awesome job man you're
a natural
but everyone makes mistakes so pay
attention to this next point
see the mark where it's gotten an x that
means you went too hard and overworked
the area when you see this open your
palm and gently push to soothe the
irritation if you keep massaging next to
a heart zone it will eventually turn to
an x should the client have any x areas
left at the end of massage it will hurt
your score
well let's just smooth that out why
don't you
do it carefully and the area will return
to normal go on fix her up
all
right
this also
right lexington this is all good right
this is all family-friendly
family friendly
i told your client you'd call her so do
it do that when you're feeling ready i
gotta take this bud you got this call me
and tell me how it goes
all right
i'm ready for massage
and nothing else
literally nothing else i'm a reputable
orc respectable and all that a person
talking and that summarizes the analysis
of our options for transitioning the new
accounts receivable management
software's illusion
okay
uh oh is that a sore spot we'll need a
decision on this before the end of the
quarter which is coming up quickly so
jesus christ
i've hurt your eyes looked in
i've hurt your eyes also blurt
madame president your thoughts
i'll need to review it personally
have the file sent to my assistant for
now everyone dismissed
oh yes absolutely i'll make sure it gets
done
[Music]
bro
i can't spend another moment in these
wretched chairs i suppose you can't big
old mosaic blur that i couldn't
understand
okay what do we have here
full body massage okay easy enough all
right
time to make some money
and increase my reputation as a
family-friendly orc massage parlor
thalia
thalia
respiration
like to make an appointment your least
available please well you're in luck all
right
family friendly
[Music]
hi um excuse me hello oh hi
you're not seeing a client now yes
surely you have time for a walk-in
[Music]
family friendly hey
i saw your reviews and i simply couldn't
resist i have this problem you see with
my um my back could a strong handsome
work like yourself help me with that um
i don't know what my handsomeness has to
do with my massaging abilities but uh i
will do my uh best all right let's see
what we got going on here you got some
lump
family friendly is it a family friend
there's a family friendly game it's a
family friendly video i'm a family
friendly channel
everything's gonna be fine no one's
gonna think anything weird to me no
one's gonna think anything's gonna be
possibly wrong it's a highly rated
keyboard
i'm right about that thing i'm right
about it i'm right i'm right
i see you got some lumbar issues here
let me see if i can
let's just hammer this out here
yep that's what i call a proper hammer
that
looks in please dear lord censor all
this i am so family friendly
that it almost hurts
cheer lord please censor everything
there we go a little bit of the shoulder
this is your solar plexus uh going into
the third rhomboid area of your uh
scapular uh
flapulence
these cavulators need a little bit of
undulation what are you what is
happening what is happening what are you
what
another satisfied customer
all right thanks so much for uh stopping
by that was nice but you can make me
feel even better next time can't you
i'll uh do my best always venture to try
to leave my uh customers satisfied
they can't ban me
they can't ban me like they can't ban me
they would never ban me man it's not
often you see a big sims walking blur
coming through your office
hello hork massage
there you are taking your sweet time
answering huh you're on the clock now
buddy answer the phone the moment it
rings kabeesh i got some bad news one of
your customers complained online you
need to work on your technique if you
want to keep them coming back
remember that app i installed for you to
buy upgrades and training equipment
start using it and it's coming out of
the pocket for now get to it okay
whatever you say pal
we provide the best products i trust
that that's for push-up
all right weighted lever strengthening
the strength of the orc affects the
duration of the massage
all right
works for me are those some sexy boxes
lixie and blur those boxes just in case
oh wow look at that
oh that's nice
uh
interesting i guess but
all right well i'm now broke who's that
who's there
looks like you took my advice and
trained yourself up glad to see it man
keep it up so you don't fall behind by
the way i forgot to clarify this before
so this vip is a setup they're paying me
directly i got to make my investment
back somehow
if you want more cash for yourself get
that door open and get more normal
clients coming what are you waiting for
all right all right my man let's talk
about your regular clients these are
your bread and butter your everyday
customers once you open for business
clients can come in any time
hi
hello when you have a normal client on
the table listen to what they want don't
get started until you can tell what they
need it's your job to fulfill their
request perfectly
[Music]
when you see this icon that means you
should get those hands working to the
beat time your move is just right to
satisfy the client well then get to work
big guy that money won't make itself
hm what
why does this sound familiar
i don't
how how do i do what you're asking
[Music]
i did it
[Applause]
oh
i just click
hell yeah
hey
that's pretty good
keep doing it
[Music]
easy there's money in the bag money in
the bag
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right i think it's time for a vip
i think anyway
appointment early is available yeah come
on in
you're apparently one of these vips hop
right on the table let's see if we can
can work out some of the the damage uh
let's see this uh this scapular needs a
little bit of movement there that's good
there
[Music]
all right easy let's get down here on
the knee as everyone knows one of the
most uh sensitive spots uh for stress
and then let's finish it off
this and uh schwa bam looks like we're
gonna have a satisfied customer and
you're gonna have a good day
all right you're welcome
what is happening
is an alien about to burst out of your
chest
all right
people have done worse than this on
youtube and they are still allowed to
make videos they can
they would never ban me i'm too
important to be banned
well actually
exquisite i knew i was right to trust
your technique
did you
alright thank you
what is this oh new why new
why new
i know it's only been a few days
but i'm already feeling worn out again
you know i'll leave it all up to you
oh don't worry
ah hello
you know it's difficult to truly feel
your handiwork with all my
clothes on isn't there something you can
do about that mr orc
um
i would feel a lot more comfortable if
you kept your clothes on oh okay well
this is totally fine all right i thought
it was gonna be something untoward
wham
you could please stop that
uh shush
if you could shush that'd be uh
i believe that's correct terminology is
shush
and look at this is gonna be 100
satisfied
that's how i do that's how i do
honestly you are more clothed than you
were before and i think that's a little
bit of a strange thing to say
hey hold on hold on
this is actually much more uh family
friendly than what it
what
what
listen up there's a slightly different
type of massage your client's not going
to tell you exactly where to work so
feel around first you sure it takes a
training to find where she's hurting
um
okay
uh how about your uh your quadriceps
that uh that
as you get closer to the primary you'll
notice the area pulsing in color
uh congratulations you found it massage
carefully and voila see our attention is
melting away
not really
i know you're kind of new to this but
remember your job is to satisfy the
client in a way this is its own reward
if you know what i'm saying i don't
know what you're saying
there we go just a good old belly
scratch
there you go
what
[Music]
all right thanks for showing up um
that'll be 400.
come back any time now year i'll give
you a coupon every tenth
who what am i looking at
huh
i'm so tired of this
yeah i've been going to this new massage
place in the west end it's run by an orc
yeah an orc he's huge but he does such
an amazing job
kind of bird lady
massages huh
bird lady
guess i'll try needs an appointment fine
what a pain well i mean i'm a busy orc i
got a lot of uh work business to do ava
very reputable work business here
nothing untoward nothing unsavory and
frankly i'd rather have a
client with a lot more clothes
hi
i'm here
you are
hi
you can fix me right
i can fix your muscle soreness i don't
know if i can fix any other problems
that you might be having uh not exactly
a therapist uh well
masseuse
you
that is a sh
sheer
top of pure pixelated nothingness that i
can't see it's cool if i'm on my phone
yeah sure i don't care
seems like everything's sore um
all right if i just whale on your wings
i'm gonna wail on your wing here oh man
i'm gonna have to back off
wailing on the wing uh wailing on your
other wing now
slam
perfect
perfect
oh damn it
so it doesn't it doesn't stop until it
goes green
okay so i gotta work this one out
bloop
okay that took a bit of doing so i gotta
be careful about that
and another another satisfied
customer
yeah there you go ava oh are we not done
did i miss a spot oh i did
that
i'm coming for the sore spot
done
hey thanks so much for waiting
all right cool watch your wings on the
way out uh that'll be five thousand
dollars
thank you
feels good barely hurts at all see you
next time that's what i aim to please i
aim to please not in that way but i aim
to please
about to take a [ __ ] on my porch
i guess i could try that again neck
hurting again give me give me an
appointment give me appointment
gimmick appointment
my wings are bothering me today can you
do them too i mean i did them last time
essential oils do they actually work i
couldn't tell you i don't use oils or
any lubricants to be perfectly honest i
kind of just start wailing wham
just really
slam into the tootsie
that's what we do here that's what we do
wham
that's what i do anyway that's what i do
just like this
big meaty claws if you know what i'm
talking about which i think i think you
do
i think you do
if this is my last video that i make
i just want
i mean why would it be the last video
that i make why would it be why would it
be it wouldn't be why would it be why
would it be explain to me one reason why
this video shouldn't exist on youtube
completely unage restricted huh you
gotta tell me that you can't you can't
cause you [ __ ] and you don't know why
you are making up all the nonsense
you're making this weird
you're the one who's perturbing this
wham
how about a little bit on this one
another satisfied customer you know how
you said you wanted your wings massaged
i actually read between line there knew
you wanted entirely exclusively lower
body treatment
all below the waist if you know what i'm
talking about and i think you do
[Laughter]
these are bird feet
okay
louise
all right and you're welcome
you are welcome
you're welcome
that'll be 28 325
oh it's uh oh
melting away the stress
a shoulder rub is exactly what i think
you need
ion warmer
colder
warmer cold colder red hot i'm hit
wherever the hell this muscle is
attaching this uh wing joint oh
ah there we go
you got it
oh whoa
contain your jiggly self ah we don't
need any of that that'll be another
thirty thousand dollars please and uh
i'm gonna add on another hundred cause i
know you're gonna poop on my porch feels
good barely is it all all right
see you around
another
god alexian
my entire channel's career is dependent
on your ability to censor this properly
i know hoonie pop was similar but my god
this is just like i'm trying not to
cross the line i'm desperately trying
not to cross the line
got a new lead chief wants you to check
it out
lucian how does it feel knowing that the
future of this channel and
i guess your ability to edit my videos
your very job at the moment is uh all
relying on your ability to properly blur
this
everything that i'm doing right now
could spell the absolute end for all
that is markiplier and it's all reliant
on you to make this as family-friendly
as possible no did you did did you
forget anything did you forget anything
did you replace all the sounds all those
weird snow even me saying moon you need
to replace that with something else so
people don't even think that something
unfamily friendly is happening oh you
think you thought of everything but did
you why don't you look into the future
or the past when is this disclaimer
being made aren't you putting it at the
beginning so people know that it's going
to be a little bit dangerous or do you
want to save it till the end but you
don't want people to know where you're
going to put it
where are you going
did you just blur my face
good call good call good call
right let's see what we got here who do
we have here what are you talking about
what do you mean
recently the crime rate in the western
has been increasing rapidly and citizens
living in the surrounding area are urged
to be more aware of their surroundings
please report any suspicious activity to
the police right away
okay
match
probably he might at least know
something
[Music]
hello
hello
are you suggesting that looks like me
i'm looking for this man do you
recognize him
[Music]
not many other orcs around here if you
know him come out and tell me right now
it's a little judgmental no idea hmm
fine but
what sort of business are you running
here
it's a massage parlor you're a masseuse
really
you're not busy right now are you give
me a massage then shouldn't be a problem
for you if this place is above board i
mean it is
but are you willing to pay my exorbitant
rates and also be completely
family-friendly from top to bottom
especially the bottom
i will not compromise the integrity of
my channel for someone like you whoever
you may be i don't know who you are but
i know you're going to be family
friendly don't give you that look we
received complaints about suspicious
people coming and going here an
orchestra sounds fishy to me
you smell fishy to me
because you probably eat fish don't you
cause you're a cat okay all right sure
hop on the table keep your clothes on
look at this complexity look at this
tapestry of pain
what is this nonsense
wham that's what you get
shush
shush
[Music]
my channel it depends on you shushing
i mean whatever is replaced uh with
like the [ __ ] goofy noises from when
he popped
just all the noises replacing their
unity oh my god
it's all fine guys it's all fine it's
all fine
all fine
very very much too fine
i got your toes
and shabbat
that's how i do satisfied
what am i doing
what am i doing
what am i doing oh what am i doing what
am i doing what am i doing i don't know
what i'm doing what am i doing what am i
doing why am i doing it why am i doing
this why am i i'm
i know exactly what i'm doing making
entertaining content for the internet
and everyone and their families to enjoy
watch this with your mom
[Laughter]
feels like a weight's been lifted was
that really just a massage
what else would it have been i'll be
watching you carefully next time
all right sure good god it's so family
friendly good god
wow
i feel so family and friendly
the mayor would like all residents to
know that criminal elements will be
stamped out as quickly and efficiently
as possible your safety is our utmost
priority
is it now
are you sure about that i'm a little
early today that's weird what in the
i'm sorry what
no
not at all
this is
[Music]
no
no
no none of that happened that was a
different massage parlor it was a
different reality that did not occur
that's not youtube hey wait a minute
hold on you didn't see anything did you
that's not no
not what happened here why am i sweaty
i'm so sweaty oh you're so sweaty
it's fine hop on the table
massage use what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
massage wham
easy
easy peas me
easy appeases me
see
i don't know how this is gonna go yeah
let's try it
all right that worked
uh
maybe
no that would never work ah
baba booey no that would also never work
uh
am i gonna have enough yeah i'll have
enough i'll have enough
if you could shush i'm trying to
concentrate on your soreness
so uh
don't do whatever you're doing do i have
enough to get through this do i need to
hammer something out
oh
okay the circles are all the ones that
are going to be affected
oh it's going to be close could be down
to the wire
i don't know if i'm going to make it
satisfy customer come on
what are you doing
what is happening where's my hand ah
okay we're fine
okay uh
there you go just a sore shoulder
happens to us all when you're on the job
how about a nice scalp massage
there we go
nope
there we go
you got it
here too please
you do wanna oh
neck
there we go
there we go
[Music]
seems like you know where you're doing
but i'm not through with you i'll be
back okay all
right you got it
anywho
i'll be on patrol today so you better
get ready don't even think about
avoiding me
why would i think about avoiding you why
would anybody be thinking about avoiding
you i saw it i knew it you were doing
something illegal to another client i
was right
[Music]
what are you talking about wait what do
you mean she requested it no way i
believe that
what are you talking about if you're
forcing your clients i'll put you away
you keep saying they come voluntarily
prove it
what are you talking about
massages they come for massages
put your goddamn clothes on what
[Music]
i should
call
susan would just
i maybe maybe maybe i don't call susan
maybe i don't let susan maybe i know
it's easier to ask for forgiveness than
it is to ask for permission
and it's family friendly there's nothing
weird going on with it
as long as alexia does the job right
we're all we're okay and i trust lexi
and i trust alexander i trust like she
had 100 100 percent i trust lixian i
started saying 100 100
yep
yeah just best i work on this side
a lot of things that are untoward
all these arms are short from your arms
are sore from making such drastic
accusations
that are completely fabricated
in every way
well i didn't do too good
well that's not good
that's not good
well hey you know uh
i barely feel any difference what's your
angle i bet you're part of this just a
front i bet you're just a front
just look at your
back
fridge i need more money
well you know
this is what it's all about
just making sure that you run a
reputable business just because other
people have these preconceived notions
of who you are just based on being a
giant orc
doesn't mean anything
it's judgmental it's prejudice it's like
it's not fair i'm here trying to uphold
my
values my beliefs and try to provide a
good service for people
to feel better about their lives i'm
here trying to make sure that they all
leave satisfied
and happy
and are able to tackle the problems of
their lives whatever those may be in the
future i
am giving them the ability to face their
problems head on and that way they are
unafraid to go into the world and
succeed in life i am making the world a
better place and all these people that
keep coming in here assuming that
something unsafery is occurring just
like you coming into this video assuming
that uh something unsavory was happening
here
that's a judgment on me and that's you
judging me why do you even feel good
about yourself i haven't even given you
a massage
so when i open up my massage parlor i
don't want anyone thinking
that anything
unsavory could possibly be happening in
that massage barlow because there
wouldn't be
my tail
all right okay well family friendliness
achieved here's my tv rating
wow g
rated for general audience ready for
g-spot oh god oh no what a wonderful
wholesome experience what a fantastic
totally cool
very chill time playing a cool video
game that definitely won't get my
channel banned and everyone is going to
leave this happier than they've ever
been
you